We Begin this half hour with a new breed
of robots in Japan there are robots
modeled after cute dogs baby seals and
of course humans but a promising new
area of Robotics was inspired by one of
the world's least-like creatures Lucy
Craft visited a lab in Tokyo and has
this report
hear them or load them snakes are made
for movement armless and legless with a
ribbon for a body snakes can sidewind
crawl and undulate across the most
forbidding terrain this versatility has
inspired robots that act like serpents
robot designer motoyaso Tanaka of
Tokyo's University of Electro
communication admits he's Charmed by
snakes
snakes have long thin bodies that are
perfect for getting in and out of tight
spaces their length allows them to climb
over High obstacles
weighing about 20 pounds with cameras in
its head and tail this snakebot has
joints Motors and sensors so it can
climb stairs with ease slink over
unsteady piles of debris
and Slither through pipes
after floods hit Western Japan in 2018
Tanaka's snakebot wriggled into a ruined
house allowing the homeowner to search
for his belongings remotely
Tanaka said future snake thoughts will
search for victims
he said since the snake bot's weight is
distributed across its body it can move
through environments without disturbing
them snakebots may become a household
accessory if you've ever wondered what
it's like to be wrapped in the coils of
a boa constrictor well introducing the
snake robot that gives a massage
perhaps not the best way to relax
but a scientists try to recreate the
reptile's smoothest moves they're also
dreaming up tricks never seen in the
wild
hoys like a cobra and fitted with a
grabber tool the snakebot can turn off a
water valve
or open a drawer
Tanaka said real snakes have just one
head but a snake bot could open a door
with its mouth hold it open and enter
the room tail first Tanaka said his
snake robot will be deployed as early as
this year to inspect damage at the
crippled Fukushima daiichi nuclear plant
ushering in a future where snakes won't
just creep us out they'll come to our
rescue for CBS Saturday morning Lucy
Craft Tokyo